the fashion for tonight and the ring and
celebrating this movie with this look
somewhat fine a little brocade and
Judy's honor rent a just festive and fun
and David Webb my favorite I was
wondering if Ray we're gonna come in a
little homage to Judy because you've
kind of been doing it Oh Maj - Judy and
some of these press spam I didn't notice
[Music]
[Applause]
one of the things that really struck me
in this film was the fact that Judy was
sort of told throughout the film you
know listen if you don't want to do it
there's someone waiting in the wing
there's a hundred girls waiting in the
wing to be you have you ever experienced
that or felt that way like well if I
don't take this job 100 people are
waiting to do be a star like me well now
I kinda tend to run my own race you know
that was a different time back then
when Judy was entering into movie
business I mean that was the zenith of
culture not just pop culture because as
Americans we all shared the same
cultural experiences we all listened the
same records the same songs on the radio
and the movies played for months at a
time in the movie theater so we were all
watching the same things than it was
shaping the conversation so to be part
of that during her during her time
entering the MGM studio system I mean
that was everybody has their trouble
I've had mine
I just want what everybody wants I seem
to have a harder time getting it she
gets a little rebellious at times when
she's being told what to do and who to
be jumping in the pool scene is a great
example of that in the film do you ever
feel rebellious in Hollywood do you feel
like you're like you've got you make me
do this I'm out like I said I was from a
race do you have a favorite Judy Garland
movie well I love maybe in st. Louie who
doesn't and Wizard of Oz and I could go
on singing I just love I could go on
singing love it and what do you make of
all of this I heard all your friends are
coming out tonight in Hollywood to
celebrate with you how cool is that it's
very cool yeah I know that's a pretty
good day
[Music]